[Música]
sí
aquí soy un chiquillo hemos visto juanma
que contaba los 60 cuanto los 40
entonces me siento joven y bueno voy a
contar la historia pues de nada de una
persona que como todos sabemos el mejor
tiempo para emprender en la vida es
ahora ya mí es ahora me llegó hace seis
años cuando cumplir los 40 pues me
replanteé de ciertas cosas de la vida
jaime veis esa es la foto mía en el
traje de época chaqueta de punto
pantalón de rayas igual que carlitos del
cuéntame para los que somos un poco más
duros pues ese soy yo una persona
corriente que hace cosas corrientes que
viven en una pequeña capital como es
cuenca muy bonita por cierto pero qué es
lo que me pasa pues que tengo un sueño
grande y como tengo un sueño después he
intentado hacer cosas para diferenciarme
bueno soy el menor de cuatro hermanos
tres chicas yo el pequeño el mimado de
la casa me crearon una familia muy
humilde pero muy feliz bueno a los 16
años pasó una cosa que cambió mi vida
mi madre falleció en un accidente
doméstico
y tuve una suerte que lo hizo en en mis
brazos y gracias a dios pude saber que
no pudo hacer nada para salvarla y ahí
en ese momento supe lo importante que es
la actitud y la resiliencia cuando doy
charlas de seguridad informática defino
resiliencia como la capacidad que tiene
el sistema informático de recuperarse en
el mínimo tiempo posible con la mínima
pérdida de información
en mi caso tuve que recuperarme de
trauma y bueno al siguiente día
mercé la mochila y me fui a mi instituto
durante los siguientes días años me fui
a vivir con mi hermana mayor pero bueno
tampoco encajaba en la vida con tu
hermana tu cuñado tus dos sobrinos al
final que hice buscarme la independencia
económica sin que mi familia lo supiera
pues estaba estudiando informática dejé
mis estudios porque de repente le dije
me incorporo he presentado una oposición
y tengo una plaza fija como funcionario
en la cual me siento muy orgulloso y
llevo 26 años trabajando en la
administración y como soy una persona
muy proactiva pues bueno he aprovechado
en la administración para seguir
formándome
pues hasta aquí todo lo normal entonces
últimamente me ha rodeado de gente como
vosotros estudiantes gente muy joven en
los cuales siempre me decían con la vida
que tienes para que te complicas la vida
ahora tienen esas historias y yo lo que
quiero ser funcionario como tú y bueno
efectivamente yo les digo yo si tuviera
que repetir y no necesitara esa
independencia económica pues hacer una
cosa luchar por vuestro sueño no te
puede mantener tu padre de dos años mal
si luchas y no te gusta o no consigues
lo que hay bueno pues ya está prepárate
la oposición luego si quieres o bueno o
haz como ha dicho es típico que hemos
visto antes que ya te contratar a un
tercero para que luchen por sus sueños
esto es cuestión de elegir en la vida lo
que uno quiere entonces bueno pues a
partir de ahí lleve mi carrera de
funcionario que es lo que pasa que a lo
largo de este trabajo está durante ocho
años investigando conflictos a través de
las nuevas tecnologías de internet y
cuando iba con mi compañero pues eso a
la sede judicial a defender ese informe
y observaba la poca formación que tienen
los abogados al respecto
y entre él y yo siempre hemos bromea si
estuviéramos nosotros en el otro lado
nos podrían haber apretado mucho más de
lo que nos ha apretado y entonces pero
bueno eso es esa ciudad no la tengo yo
sólo he escuchado a un fiscal
especialista en delitos informáticos
jorge bermúdez en una conferencia en la
ruta con dijo una frase muy potente es
los jueces son de martes la los hackers
son de venus y la pobre justicia siempre
en medio igual siempre es evidencia pues
esa falta de especialización en la
justicia e incluso esa falta de
regulación y ánimo a los jóvenes que el
mundo está lleno de oportunidades y de
problemas todos sabemos miles de
problemas elegirlos uno e intentar
resolver ese problema es así de fácil
y tenemos todos muchos problemas en la
vida
bueno qué es lo que pasó que me hizo
cambiar pues bueno
estamos hace seis años sábado 13 de
abril el día siguiente cumplir los años
pues eso de los 40 mil va a sentar y un
deportista nato con curioso y que me
encanta el deporte qué es lo que hace
pues buscas un reto
voy a hacer un reto duro para verlos
joven que soy y en añadía dos locos más
en cogimos las bicicletas son unas
pruebas nos dejaron en ávila en la bici
de montaña un gps un track y dijeron
ahora volvéis a madrid y bueno pues una
jornada muy dura muy bonita había
agotado y cuando llegué al día siguiente
domingo tenía que celebrar con mi pareja
que vive en madrid familia pues bueno es
pues eso el c40 cumpleaños ella lleva
una vida totalmente diferente a la mía
ella trabaja en una multinacional con un
ritmo de vida como puede llevar a mucha
gente del abismo ritmo de vida muy duro
entonces ella me dice tú con el tiempo
que tienes no te gustaría hacer algo
diferente en la vida algo de lo que te
pudiera sentir orgulloso bueno y me dijo
que estarías haciendo tú de aquí cuando
cumpla los 50 y respondí en cuestión de
segundos dije soy funcionario desde hace
20 años poco ha cambiado la vida algún
incremento algún decremento unas horas
más unas horas menos pero poca cosa y
entonces le dije bueno si esta semana
estoy con mi hija estoy separado con la
custodia compartida pues si estoy con mi
hija pues bueno por la cuidaré esta
semana y si no pues vete a buscarme por
las montañas de cuenca que me vas a
encontrar
pero esa semilla me fue generando dudas
y dije bueno
voy a cambiar algo de mi vida o voy a
seguir haciendo lo que es y entonces me
dije porque no voy a hacer lo que he
pensado con mi compañero esa poca
formación que hay en abogados y voy a
empezar esa carrera entonces tomé la
decisión porque en la vida que pasa
relación a las buenas palabras están muy
bien pero si no haces hechos no llegas a
ningún sitio entonces que hice bueno me
matriculé en derecho ya veis después de
20 años casi sin estudia arreglado
alguien del coach de ciencias puras los
que soy de por aquí física química
dibujo técnico matemática de repente en
la universidad de la universidad de
derecho
la mitad de la media de edad de los
alumnos 18 o 20 años de 40 bueno me
costó un poquito encajar con ellos
me veían más como su padre el estudiante
los alumnos empezó la rivalidad una
buena nota no gran y esther pero
primer examen historia del derecho lunes
vamos a cambiarlo el lunes el lunes fin
de semana por casualidad tenía un fin de
semana en zaragoza todos conocemos la
zona del tubo de zaragoza pues esas
tapas sales recuerdos 2000 está mi
pareja dormía yo me levantaba al baño a
estudiar esa historia de la historia
romana
qué es lo que pasó con el examen
claramente suspendido y entonces me
replanteé me dije gasto tiempo y dinero
y no quiero gastar ninguna de estas dos
cosas o sigo adelante o lo dejo y me
vino muy bien suspender ese primer
examen para remontar y remonte las
asignaturas que no saqué el primer año
porque tampoco me matriculé en todas no
vaya a ser que no me gustase
y en cuatro años logré sacar mi carrera
así que los éxitos no están de hoy para
mañana vivimos una sociedad que es
inconstante que queremos rapidez y lo
queremos ya y mi sueño estaba a 6 años
entonces necesitaba lo que yo me llamo
mi isla de libertad entonces es decir
necesito motivación o sea si yo bien mis
sueños de aquí a 6 años lo dejo y me
cree parte de mi tiempo libre me crea lo
que yo llamo una idea libertad que era
mi isla del soñador entonces pues bueno
visualizaba mi proyecto iba haciendo
cosas iba dándoles vueltas para ver qué
nombre le ponía siempre un poco inquieto
hasta que de repente un verano en 2016
navegando por internet observó un curso
de la escuela de organización industrial
eoi un curso de emprendimiento en cuenca
que tampoco encuentra hay tanto
emprendimiento del primer curso y me
llamó la atención ya que rellene un
formulario y lo rellena y ahí se quedó
la cosa olvide un poco el tema a los
tres o cuatro días me llama vicente la
directora del curso a la cual tengo que
darle gran parte de agradecimiento por
mis éxitos y por esa confianza me dijo
que necesitamos digo bueno lo rellenado
pero si todavía ni siquiera acaba la
carrera no pasa nada ven hace el curso y
gracias a ella y otra forma de motivar
ya sea a la gente a través de la
confianza a través de la implantación de
un modelo de negocio me dijo prototipo
saca algo en estos cuatro meses que
tenemos de formación y nosotros a través
de la de hoy te vamos a dar a este
impulso que necesita bueno pues como
tenía mis la libertad creada al final
pues me busque un nombre para salir una
marca que la mía fue y es tengo grados
esta combinación de tecnológico y grados
de abogados en el futuro abogado que
espero poder hacer
bueno
fui validando la idea me creé mi propia
web hacer funcionar y venir a una
familia humilde por la impresión que
dice tampoco fue excesiva y me permitió
salir adelante
qué es lo que hice pensando en grande
digo no vaya a ser que tengo gatos
triunfel bueno pues vamos a hacer una
pequeña inversión vale y ya que no
minuto nada ni cobro pues voy a gastar
poco dinero bueno dije 150 euros 111 en
el registro de marca está bien dos euros
el dominio yo me hice mi web me compre
mil tarjetas que las tengo por ahí las
voy repartiendo que dicen que es un blog
porque efectivamente es lo que es y como
era más baratas en italia pues afinando
fui a italia con dolor de mi corazón mis
tarjetas 18 euros cualquiera tiene una
tarjeta visita de una calidad alta
entonces bueno ya que pierdo 150 euros y
yo soy muy cabezón esto ya no lo voy a
dejar y os animo ahora a una sociedad
información que vivimos validar un
proyecto ya veis lo económico que eso
sea a través de tecnologías línea
startup canvas développement scrum otras
metodologías que hay eres capaz de
arrancar un proyecto o de validarlo por
una inversión de menos de 300 euros
quién no sueña por 200 euros
y el eso me ha dado mis éxitos y cuál es
mi éxito mi éxito es hoy poder estar
aquí porque si yo no hubiera arrancado
ese paso jamás estaría aquí sé que
estaría hoy un día no tengo esta semana
mi hija pues estaría en cuenca corriendo
con la bicicleta con mis amigos con una
vida cómoda salido esa zona de confort
que tanto hemos hablado aquí que es tan
difícil de salir pero que la verdad es
tan bonita y me ha dado esos logros de
poder contar con pasión y aquello que
llevo dentro con ese brillo en los ojos
me ha permitido pues poder participar en
varios congresos de seguridad
informática el año pasado estuve en una
tv es en albacete estado en zaragoza en
el mes pasado normalmente de lo que
suelo hablar es eso de evidencias
digitales y tanto al perfil técnico como
el perfil jurídico pero ese es el tema
este tema de motivación es que la
primera vez lo estoy haciendo y la
verdad que para mí es un orgullo
aquí os voy a contar un proverbio chino
que llega el maestro chino llena de 56
rocas grande una vasija y las introduce
y entonces le pregunta al alumno como
está la vasija y el alumno dice llena
maestro entonces el maestro saca una
bolsa de arena y la vuelca y cabe la
vasija el ife como está llena maestro y
saca un vaso y lo llena
vemos que hay varias para mí las rocas
en la vida es aquello importante en lo
que cualquier decisión que tome va a
afectar a ella y para mí mi roca son mi
familia mi pareja mi hija trabajo y
ahora mi proyecto esas son las rocas
todo lo que intento hacer en la vida es
intentar equilibrar las y de lo que más
orgulloso me siento es que en este duro
camino de seis años compatibilizando una
custodia compartida compatibilizando mi
hija tenía un año y medio desde entonces
o sea si un padre bastante entregado y
me siento muy orgulloso por ello en esta
semana que es de mi hija no se le quitó
ni con los estudios hasta que ella no se
acueste ya partir de ahí empiezan una
actividad de lograr ese equilibrio en la
vida
de las cosas de las que más orgullosa en
el sentido o sea hay tiempo para hacer
las cosas ya la gente joven le digo con
la cantidad tiempo que tenéis que esos
hacer hasta la ropa ropa limpia comida
todo ya tenéis toda la vida por delante
y si fuera es capaz de foco con 20
años la teoría de las 10.000 horas
seríais expertos con 25 años en
cualquier cosa es las preparadas
pero bueno no todo es bonito porque
cuando uno empieza un nuevo camino
vienen los miedos el miedo de los
desconocidos yo estoy en mi trabajo
llevo 20 años bueno ahora ya 26 haciendo
algo similar me siento muy cómodo y muy
pocas cosas me pueden pues eso pues
improvisar y sacarme o buscar un
problema y este nuevo camino me hace
pues eso pues que surjan miedos pero yo
a lo largo de la vida he visto que puedo
tomar la decisión desde dos lados
o sea puedo tomar decisiones desde el
amor o desde el miedo desde el amor para
ver lo que quiero hacer o desde el miedo
para evitar aquello que no quiero que
pase y siempre os aconsejo que toméis
decisiones desde el corazón
el sábado pasado tuve quizás el último
examen de esta larga carrera un examen
más duro de lo que me esperaba y por la
tarde pues bueno saqué unas entradas
para ir al teatro porque me apetecía
reírme salió con salgo con mi pareja el
14 como estar reñido como te ha gustado
la obra y es que tenía tan vacío de risa
de alegría de buen rollo que desde que
entré me apetecía reír
por qué pues porque esa tensión que
tenía acumulada fui capaz de sacarla
para que tener cuidado porque porque
todo tiene un riesgo en la vida pero
aquellos algo que os hagáis una pregunta
y una pregunta de verdad que es lo que
peor que podría pasar si hicieras eso si
tú pones realidad a esos riesgos si un
día te enfrentas a ellos vas a saber
solucionar lo solos tienes previsto
entonces búscate esa red
búscate es el colchón económico que te
permita dos años poder tener una
independencia financiera si tienes un
trabajo no lo dejes o sea intenta
compatibilizar lo al máximo valida tu
proyecto y quieres lograr de validar lo
pide una excedencia si puedes y si no
será el momento de dejarlo pero no hay
que tomar una decisión sin tener esas
esas medidas serias de seguridad
para finalizar bueno yo ya tengo mi
sueño mi sueño se llama tecnoga 2 espero
que este verano puede hacer un despacho
de abogados especialistas en prueba
tecnológica y podríamos dar esa defensa
jurídica y ese asesoramiento tanto a
empresarios como abogados generalistas
como a cualquier particular donde la
prueba de cargo en un proceso judicial
sea una evidencia digital y en que nos
vamos a diferenciar pues que tengo una
experiencia profesional tengo una
formación técnica y ahora voy a dar esa
defensa desde un punto de vista jurídico
por eso animo a todos los que estéis
aquí sentados que tengáis el compromiso
hoy de dar un paso buscarlos un sueño
grande pero alcanzable vale que salgáis
de esa zona de confort en el que sea y
tenemos objetivos retadores que hagáis
las cosas con pasión sobre todo
disfrutar y disfrutar en el camino y por
último que seáis felices gracias
[Aplausos]